if god is perfect why would he have to
manifest himself as something imperfect
something that eats something that
defecates something that gets hungry
something that dies if jesus christ
which we believe is a prophet by the way
so peace be upon him if he came into
existence meaning he was born well
documented that cannot be all eternal
and so i'm still not getting all right
so the problem is is that
he did something that you don't think he
would do if that is supposed to be an
example of a contradiction i do not
accept that that is a contradiction if
god has three parts this makes him
contingent or dependent upon on these
three parts how does that make him
unlimited all-powerful all-knowing and
when i asked you this you said you're
breaking a commandment and when i asked
you that was okay so if something
logically doesn't make sense why would i
have to accept that for me to get the
message from gato so you're saying just
because you don't understand why god
chose to do something i don't know i'm
saying that's a clear-cut logical
fallacy and it is not illogical you
can't nail the father to the cross
illogical that's a logical fallacy if
god is all powerful it shouldn't happen
on three parts
because by definition without one part
it's no longer complete have i ever
sneaked in talking about god try to to
undermine islam saying oh look what
about this verse in the quran and this
verse and the quran and then all i mean
i don't know if you want like i brought
this before in the last room that we
talked about religion and you got angry
at me for saying it on the stream but i
already said it but you you did tell me
and i don't want you to get mad at me or
call me a snake but you did say that
islam is a false religion yes and that's
what
i brought this before in the last room
that we talked about religion and you
got angry at me for saying it on the
stream but i already said it but you you
did tell me and i don't want you to get
mad at me or call me a snake but you did
say that islam is a false religion yes
and you yeah that's what i'm talking
about i stand by that but
he brought that up i got mad at you in
the context of we were talking to a
muslim and i
my goal is not to debate or prove
muslims wrong my only goal in doing any
of this is spreading the gospel and it
is not wise to try and spread the gospel
to someone after you've insulted them
about something that they care deeply
about okay you should question your
beliefs
islam you have three muslims above you
right now why don't you ask some
questions well and also one more thing
you said that you you you claimed islam
to be false that's a bold claim right so
gotta ask you questions for that and
then number two you were saying that uh
what i was doing was talking about the
bible and and how in in the bible there
are bold-faced contradictions that we
talked about but you're saying they're
not contradictions you said that guy was
twisting things out of context and
you're saying that i'm breaking the
second commandment or something like
that right i don't know the commandments
but you're saying i was going against
something if god wanted the clear-cut
message to be in the bible why would
there be logical fallacies that i have
to accept with blind faith to then get
salvation and accept the bible
so
all right let's just look at the
situation that just happened right with
this dude that just came on here
i do not accept that that was a
contradiction he's choosing to interpret
that verse one way and it's a way that
takes that verse out of the context of
the greater book of john right
he chooses to interpret the word and to
somehow mean a separation which is not
how well how the word and is ever used
in language period one so he chooses to
do that and so
these are this is an example of if that
is supposed to be an example of a
contradiction i do not accept that that
is a contradiction i wasn't talking
about that though okay what would you
say
i asked you a question that if god has
three parts this makes him contingent or
depended upon on these three parts how
does that make him unlimited
all-powerful all-knowing and when i
asked you this you said you're breaking
a commandment and when i asked you that
i was like okay so if something
logically doesn't make sense
why would i have to accept that for me
to get the message from gato
all right
so you're saying just because you don't
understand why god chose to do something
i don't know i'm saying that's a
clear-cut logical fallacy and you're
saying if you if you use that way of
thinking which transcends god's way
right you said god worked in a serious
ways then i'm the one that is flawed for
that but i'm saying if god chose a
simple message why would he choose
something that is illogical
and my argument is that it is not
illogical it is not illogical you can't
nail father to the cross it is illogical
that's a logical fallacy if god is all
powerful it shouldn't depend on three
parts
because by definition without one part
it's no longer complete
wait so it's not that it's dependent on
three parts it's that it's a fact that
he exists in three parts and so it's not
like you're saying it as if that is
somehow god having a weakness is that is
how god exists he exists in three parts
and so i don't get how that is like and
this is why i say it's breaking the
second commandment to say that that's
not okay it's like that is what it is
and just because
i it it's not how you would do it if you
designed a god i mean that not how god
is that is just how he is
okay army feel free if you want to jump
in but so
god died for our sins is that correct
all right you're saying yeah jesus
christ the son died on the cross for our
sins yes okay and if i ask you why do
you believe that and just in a very
pious respectful way because the bible
says so
the same bible that says that the god
and jesus are separate
no so the bible does not in any point
say that jesus is not god there is not a
single verse in the bible that says
jesus is not god
jesus
is a part of the trinity
i mean that it's it's just
god exists in the capacity that he
exists for in
precisely because that's how he does you
know it's like
i don't i'm not all right so your
problem is that god manifested himself
as a human that is your problem that's
unbefitting of god
why
because if god is perfect why would he
have to manifest himself as something
imperfect something that eats something
that defecates something that gets
hungry something that dies if jesus
christ which we believe is a prophet by
the way so peace be upon him if he came
into existence meaning he was born well
documented that cannot be all eternal
and so i'm i'm still not getting all
right so the problem is is that
he did something that you don't think he
would do
no that it's a logical contradiction
like all we have
for him
believe tldr for anyone watching is just
here's god and here is everyone else
like there is no there's nothing even
close to that there's no man there's no
jesus christ jesus christ as a prophet
in our religion but it's not god that's
the thing
hey chad you're asking me to add cassidy
campbell i don't know who cassidy
campbell is i'm calling ruslan he was
trying to call me earlier but i was in a
conversation with with nicole don we
should do this again
no so all right answer and to answer
your question um and what's your name
brother what should i address you quiet
i'm saying one
all right so
who are we
to
say
to tell god that he can't manifest
himself as a human being
no one
so
if he does it what's the problem
but i'm asking what's the proof for that
though
i mean the bible and the acts that he
did
and the
god is perfect god is all all-powerful
eternal but then saying otherwise via
the sun goes against that
all right and so all right and can i can
i add someone who i think would probably
um
offer a lot to this conversation then i
think at another time i want to do it at
another time me and rami me and ramy we
gotta go pray and uh all right
we're gonna there they want to say i'd
love to we'd love to plan this schedule
we'll have you on next time okay all
right yeah brother um and yeah uh just
to answer your question again you're the
way i'm understanding it is your problem
is that
you you think it's beneath god for him
to manifest himself as a human repeat
the only time you cut off i'm saying how
i'm understanding this is you believe
that is beneath god to manifest himself
as a human being
according to the traits that god has
described himself with in the said book
that you're mentioning
and what are those traits that says that
god all knowing all of this right the
contradiction when you're saying a part
of that
can lose these qualities because then
it's no longer god that's that's my
biggest problem so he doesn't lose these
qualities he chooses
to come to earth in a form in which he
is not in his entire fatherhood fatherly
state he chose to come here you have you
cannot question one the very essence of
god means
you cannot question his decision
anything he does is right anything he
chooses to do is right and so
and also it is incorrect to think of it
as jesus is not god it's not the father
become
human
you understand in the sense of like they
all three exist eternally from the
beginning of time till the end of time
it's not as if it so and that
i think you're missing the point of it
but bro what if that's not all right let
me go to our rational faculties as
mankind like shouldn't it be something
that doesn't contradict itself though
like if it's easily palatable for like
let's say today's skeptic or today's
eighth year so today's person that
chooses blind science over religion
right
because i'm not an atheist i'm a skeptic
but i'm still believing in islam right
but i choose to like question everything
before i make that informed decision
right that's what i'm saying isn't it
something like doesn't it seem logical
that if god wanted you to accept the
message that it's something that makes
sense and so it does it makes perfect
sense to me it makes perfect sense to me
it makes perfect sense that
a being that is unbound by time space
energy i agree i agree capable of
moving through our
wrists let me try to work this
differently for you don let's say for
example one of the qualities that makes
god is that he is uh what omnipresent
right so he's an
right anyway he's eternal right now
let's say there's all these things that
make up god right on all the four armies
or whatever right now one of which being
he is eternal
when he turns himself into something
that is no longer eternal he no longer
fits
the threshold for what oh and no longer
fits like the the categories as to what
makes god so he's no now he is out of
that bound he's no longer warranted as
god he doesn't fit the requirements
because the requirements of the
foreigners and now he's lost one of them
now just because of that alone he's no
longer in a position where he can even
call himself god because
he's lost one of the he's lost he's lost
one of the qualities that makes up bro
just like corruption we as muslims don't
believe god to be omnipresent
all right so let me offer a perspective
from that one the father
never steps off of his throne at any
point in time when jesus is on earth
doing his earthly ministry so them all
being one them all being connected
there's never a point where the father
dies also um jesus's earthly body dies
but the
you know what you think you think jesus
died
i know yes jesus jesus died yes we we as
muslims also don't believe in that okay
but all right and so that's an
interesting past to go down maybe in a
future conversation where i couldn't yes
let's just another time i want to
continue on my stream but i think we
should do this another time with an
expert that you bring on don i didn't
want you to feel like you were being
attacked i didn't want you to feel like
you were like this was an unfair
conversation that was not my intention i
did not know he was coming on you know
that right
i mean yeah bro yeah no i i um are you
mad at me
no i'm not mad at you bro
i can hear like what's the
disappointment what did i do
it's just the perspective that i see it
from it's
it's um
you know maybe we can talk about it
upstream but
tell me can i say one thing before we
end this
don bro there were times in my life bro
i was depressed i was watching your
videos and i put a smile on my face and
i have too much love for you and too
much respect for you that when i see you
making claims that islam is false
something that literally makes no sense
that i at least want to give it a shot
to pick up your brain and see where
you're coming from and yeah that's my
i'm not trying to spark some beef or
anything like that no yeah i don't have
a problem with anybody on this panel i
don't have a problem with it wait it's
all levels
what do you think i did wrong
we can talk all stream bro we can talk
straight it's better you do that off
stream bro we can talk about stream but
anyway um it's been a pleasure bro yeah
no definitely thank y'all for having me
um
uh pico man it's been a pleasure too
yeah thanks for having me coming on
we'll talk again
yeah should they subscribe to our
youtube channel yo go subscribe to the
three muslims go check them out
i enjoyed having you on that was a great
conversation we could do this at another
time i think it'd be good to prepare it
i don't understand why do you think it
feels slight about me what did i do
i don't think it's done bro it's just
people they hate having cognitive
dissonance and at the end of the day
that's all we try to deliver bro i can't
understand it people in the chat saying
oh friend i don't know what i did wrong
i don't know
and he couldn't he didn't even want to
say it on the stream let me say
something in the chat if you have a
friend that just
you know agrees with every single thing
you say they don't pick at it they don't
critique it they don't want the best for
you they don't tell you when you're
wrong that's not a friend bro that's a
fault your friends check you your
friends like you know someone that tells
you as it is even if they don't agree
with you even if it hurts your feelings
that's that's a friend to me bro and if
you would rather stay blue pill then
that's all you i mean this has happened
before in the stream don is very uh
emotional and very
passionate about the bible and so when
the subject comes up and when it feels
questioned i think he he applies that
too all we can do is make the offer for
don and that's it bro okay well thanks
for coming on i appreciate it this
conversation is great peace all right
about this blessings good to meet you
my man
the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and it's using us
instead of us using it but with the adan
app you can use it in perfect alignment
with your life the adan app is already
used by 40 million believers around the
world why because it caters to your
islamic lifestyle on top of the salah
times you get their eyes
the islamic calendar ramadan calendar
suhur and iftar times
hajj and umrah guide qibla finder and
much more for free so download the
adonap now